oui c'est vrai j'ai été lolita c'est
vrai j'ai été sept femmes qu'on
pouponner qu'on dorlote mais maintenant
c'est fini maintenant je me sens forte
et solide
je cherche un homme mais pas n'importe
quel homme je cherche un homme qui me
traitent par l'enfant a tardé parce que
c'est pas gentil gentil que moi j'aime
pas ça du tout et puisque c'est celui
qui dit qui y est même à la monotonie de
la vie commune a endormi en au coeur la
prud'homie d'essence pour ranimer la
flamme vacillante du désir
nous aimerions rencontré deux messieurs
bien sous tous rapports qui partagerait
avec nous la f6 de l'avenue bosquet une
ingestion de la sonatrach société de
diffusion des engins tractable à haut
niveau de rendement qu'elle aime grand
blond aux yeux bleus sera mai mais un
jour où coeur des criques sauvages de la
riviera au printemps j'aime cette
préférence que ce soit le mari de
christiane jackson demeure au 14 rue
nationale 06 la napoule que j'ai
rencontré dire que tel de ma radio
louis là que pina josiane je suis
alsacien et j'en suis fier tout comme je
suis fier de faire partie du petit long
de ce qui aujourd'hui encore croix et
respecte les vraies valeurs
c'est un foyer que je veux fonder c'est
une famille que je veux construire femme
fardée et filles libertines abstenez
vous c'est une femme de tête et de peurs
responsable que je cherche n'importe
quelle femme de tête et de coeur
responsable du moment qu'elle ait de
gros seins et qu'elle met des porte
jarretelles site est belle comme un
camion si t'as pas peur des banlieues
rouges doit si tu dis merde à cette
société haïti qui nous avait dit tout
journal tz
si tu peux te pend au coût d'un mec tu
vois qui pue la sueur et le cambouis 1
tu vas tu veux dire si si tu dis tu dis
encore merde au conformisme tu vois à
pinhou en conformité le monsieur un et
ben alors là là tu vois toi petit tu
peux venir tu peux venir venir vivre en
écorchée vive et tout est bien
évidemment certificat de baptême est
exigé ainsi que tu eu le bac
le bateau sur le ras le bol chez les
rats le bas le minimum je sais c'est le
bac minimum s'il faut pas déconner non
plus je me suis bonjour je m'appelle
annette
j'ai 29 ans je sais pas conduire
je sais pas très bien la cuisine jeunes
à manille lire niall au cinéma alors
attention je suis une bombe de sexualité
de sensualité
les deux mélangés je t'attends toi
l'homme qui sera monde détonateur je
demande même pas de photo je changerais
bien ce bouddha contre un autre boudin
si possible vigueur s'il changerait
volontiers ce minable contre un autre
minable mais moins tard et bout d'un
minable boudent minable bout d'un sac à
merde entre google
je m'appelle rené il y a deux femmes en
moi l'une sage bien élevé aimons la vie
de famille et les jeux de société
par exemple je suis très forte au
scrabble l'autre perverse vicieuse
briseuse de ménage
bref une [ __ ] je cherche deux hommes
qui pourraient me comprendre et me
rendre heureuse évidemment des jumeaux
serait l'idéal mais je ne crois pas au
père noël
j'ai 45 ans je dirige deux
multinationales ainsi qu'une petite
scierie en province qui je le pense a
toutes les chances de devenir grandes
je partage mon temps entre la suisse
deux mois l'hiver et bisons salle et mon
bateau qui m'emmène tous les étés avec
une vingtaine d'amis vers les îles
grecques
j'ai un hobby la voiture j'en ai 9
voilà maintenant j'aimerais rencontrer
une femme qui même pour moi même et
d'ailleurs je suis prêt à payer pour
cela
si j'ai une transe alité sont
raisonnables bien entendu j'ai 40 ans je
suis cadre supérieur dans l'informatique
et je suis célibataire jeune femme douce
et aimante
c'est possible catholique viendra
prendre la main pas cela
[Musique]